Batman and Superman have had a fight
brewing for some time and it's not long
until we get to find out who wins or how
they make up for whatever I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update while
the two heroes of the title are
obviously the big draw for the upcoming
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice the
movie will also involve a variety of
other classic DC characters some of
these are featured in the latest TV spot
which came out last weekend last week it
was confirmed that there would be an
r-rated version of the movie available
when it hits home video later in the
year The Ultimate Edition will contain
extra sequences of violence that will
take the movie beyond its theatrical
pg-13 rating current batman man ben
affleck spoke to e w about the decision
to release a stronger version of the
film I'm a parent of young kids and I
feel like I wouldn't want to have a
Batman V Superman that I couldn't show
to my younger kids he said but on the
same token as an adult I like to see
movies that are r-rated I think nowadays
because we have so many means of
distribution and ways that we can do
different things it's the creative
solution to a creative challenge it was
recently reported that dawn of Justice
was tracking to make a huge box-office
impact when it arrives at the end of the
month with a predicted global take of
between 300 million and 340 million
dollars on its opening weekend will you
be going to see Batman V Superman in its
opening week whose side are you on or do
you wish that the superheroes would just
stop having rich people fights and get
back to saving the world let me know in
the comments or come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot